welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
now yeah yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't do
it either just to be clear yeah we're
joined here to make sure I'm right
saying right is it tome I yes yes um
tome Tom eight do you ever get by the
way on the phone sometimes it's super
frustrating when I mean I could I'll say
this
I could tell sometimes this
english-as-a-second-language person
they'll be like your name and all the
time they're like I'm sorry I'm like Tom
and they're like could you spell it
and they're like home like right is this
a new one it's like it should have been
one of the ones you've heard a lot so
far I've you've I do feel like it's
super short like yeah it would be like a
two syllable name like you know at least
yeah right
Christine like people can like go with
you Tom get so that it is it is like and
then you can hear people go John I'm
like no no I understand that
what's more alarming are the amount of
people who are so lazy that they've
known us for a while and they're like
house Christine doing I'm like five
years for five years we have these good
friends of ours we thought they were
pretty good friends but we haven't and
in their defense we haven't seen him in
like a couple years they've been
everyone's been traveling it's been
rough but you know we were pretty
hardcore vacations that-that-that's
together that's close and she said so
happen and what great is your oldest in
like did you call Angie the oldest yeah
it was like oh man I guess
yes we were completely out of your mind
you don't think about us at all oh yeah
we forgot you forgot who we hung out
with and gave Christmas presents to
sometimes too you know it's like I'm
kind of like defending us because we go
and we we meet more people than most
people do yeah right because like yes
and so and you know there's there are
clubs that everybody that you love and
you walk into Ryan you're like it's so
good to be back yeah and sometimes it'll
be you know let's say six or seven
people on that staff right and they all
say something to you and then yeah like
what's up dude I call everybody dude
[Laughter]
that's the worst okay tell you what I
just did this week I'm such a shithead I
was in st. lous tits and my feature act
I go oh hi nice to meet you and like the
first night went by and by the second
night he goes you know we've worked
together before like three years ago I'm
such an asshole I gotta be sorry you get
a pass though I think you know yes
headliner you get a pass it's you're
going around you're meeting so many
people working with so many people so
popular so popular yeah it's come on my
favorite sometimes people go after the
show they go you remember me an audience
person from like fucking San Francisco a
couple years ago I was guy that yelled
out pastrami sandwich like yes you
missed Rami Joan I know I remember now I
just I forgot for a second you just you
jostle it for me how about when you're
when the same thing goes down hey
remember me you're in San Francisco
having remember me yeah
yeah how's it goin good Pascack Hills
High School right you remember oh right
yeah it's not even in that context of
club right and it's something from your
like childhood or your cousin or
something like yo I'm awful I guess I
don't remember you at all well they say
that forgetting names is means that you
think more about yourself than other
people yeah you know what's wrong with
that
what about faces I tend to remember
people's faces but not always the name
mm-hmm I mean that means I'm half
observant maybe yeah you care a little
bit yeah but not enough and the truth is
you remember the names of everyone that
you want to remember right I mean yes
Yeah right Christine Christine
so unmemorable I must not be I just got
it today it was like I loved your
podcast Christine I'm like what wait how
much you love it not that much yeah yeah
we get that too about it like in the you
know when you do like press radio mm-hmm
I think it's like so it shows like a
level of just it's again it's like
laziness and and just zero regard when
they go like and then we have you on the
you know and so they have a computer and
they're like yeah you're here
it's got great podcasts called a good go
over you see your mom you couldn't just
like type that shit in and read it me
like yeah screw you yeah all right let's
open the show here we go Brad you get a
box here let's have some fun here we go
[Music]
I'm sure all of you know how do you wipe
your Christina
[Music]
we got it you got it catacombs right
Tom's good Tom skin yeah like a real
yeah yeah but then I owned it and I took
I took I got a better joke with my name
you did yeah it was a because it was
like a lot of momma poppa a lot of poop
a lot of ash and then I came up with
Papa boner
oh it was it was the mic drop in third
grade yeah figure out a way to own the
reverse the holy and they're like now
you fucking love me if you could do that
to his own name what could he do to mine
man that's so great
yeah where did you grow up again New
Jersey North Jersey North Jersey is that
like close to Philly no that's South
Jersey okay
North James is like 30 minutes outside
of New York okay and um yeah like right
on the border of like New York State you
know it was uh it was a cool spot to
grow up yeah Giants Stadium more than
Eagles stadium Meadowlands yes okay yes
mmm
are you still a big Giants fan I am it's
cool to have that like that's the thing
about sports that like you know I think
is great
the longer you know you're around is
like having a little piece of home and
having some emotional attachment to it
yeah makes that's what that's the fun
part of sports like I never have
someone's like yeah I love sports I
don't really care who I'm like then
you're not getting the thrill of it
right thrill is that you're either
really excited or super bummed out and
angry yeah that's the fun part yeah so
you're having like a pretty good time I
guess right now I mean it's up and down
all the time but like Giants are a fun
team to follow yeah they stink this year
though there's a lot of chaos but I'm
also a Yankee fan and they just got in
the playoffs and I come my whole house
is girls whoo and nobody cares yeah so I
just like walk around the house like all
yesterday Yankees are in the playoffs
let's hear and there's
like fleas we don't know what that means
but we know we don't like it yeah it was
completely math and I went through
periods especially when I was first
dating my wife where I was like yeah you
know watch a little baseball but I was
never like a all in sports guy like all
the time
yeah but then like once we had kids and
moved along and stuff I started watching
more sports because it was just a way to
shut down and just kind of like tune
them out yeah tune everything out yeah
yeah it's great especially connecting
from your life yeah yeah
wife did you see why it's interesting
because sport talk is a shorthand for
gentlemen like if you'll notice every
time we do have a guy guest Andy which
is mostly our guest now it's like sports
first I know we get it out of the way
yeah and then what's your team machine
alright good and then you can go on yeah
everything else it's like your butt
sniff yeah yeah it's strange and then
when you meet someone who's just not
into it at all and it's kind of
unsettling in a way it's like man if
you're not really anyone yeah actually
yeah I don't expect girls to like I
don't follow baseball at all but
sometimes I'll meet a guy and he'll be
like well you know I don't like really
anything but baseball and I'll be like
yeah okay but I get that like you right
you like one of the things right yeah
you like something with a ball yeah we'd
have to be really smart to enjoy now
I hit up Tom before the show and he was
like I have a huge long nail fetish you
have any is that right I love them yeah
I'm no longer the better huh this is
email from his fight gosh they were my
favorite file crazy but anyways they
asked this lady how she I actually would
think that too right if you saw these
crazy long nails yeah how do you do any
number of things but white how does she
might prove that did she pick her nose
how does she wiper but how does she work
shoes uh all of it
you can take a shit nasty oh wait she
did you see the clip in the beginning
and I don't want to direct you but did
you see when they glanced by her foot
yeah pretty sure this lady was on TLC I
think we shot we see like a super
produced segment on her oh my god
wait but no this is just I'm on I tender
hooks right now what about which is a
real sloppy one no you really got a
really wipe now she needs a permanent
bidet the wash let yeah she needs a hose
yeah in a yard yeah and a man sprays it
in there right someone with deadly
accuracy just just hands up against the
fence it's time to blast and you just
like let her collect it throughout the
day and then at 6 o'clock at night
that's when you hose her off what are
you doing with your life you're not
where but I'm saying yeah why would you
inconvenience yourself just to be like
I'm the super gross long nails person
that's her identity it's her marker it
is it's like I'm the parrot guy I'm the
exotic cat guy yeah yeah it's funny we
watched the we watched the whole segment
on this guy in Mexico with the world's
biggest penis uh-huh and it turns out
that
and it was absolutely enormous we're
talking like down at the ankle but what
they discovered when they did these
cat-scans was that the penis actually
was under all this extra skin it was
like so penis actually was let's say
whatever seven inches yeah and then he
had overgrown skin extra truck cast Ski
al roker extra skin yes it would give
you the illusion like that's all penis
but it really is excess skin so then
they go and like this guy can't go he
can't walk it just pops against his legs
and it's like facilitating elephant
trunk right so then they go does these
doctors were like you know you can't
even enjoy life with this they offered
to do a surgery with like will remove
all this excess skin and still leave you
with your above average penis right but
let you kind of function instead of
living this way but which was like a
horrible they showed like his quality of
life and he was like nah I like having
this crazy huge penis and people being
like whoa like looking at me like the
fuck is that thing yeah I'd rather have
that right then um give me back like a
normal life so yeah he wants to be
special Yeah right
they take that away from he's gotta come
up he's got to develop a skill or a
hobby or that's right he's got to sing
he's got to be something to be special
that's true now he's like here you go
ladies
yeah rummage through this laundry basket
and see if you can find it and he's like
it just drips all day it's not even
functional he can't have intercourse
with people he can't know let me just
drape it over them like a parachute it's
wrapped up in like a gauze like he
doesn't even know it's it's just so
unusable Wow it's really weird these
kind of treats it like a it's like
asking a Siamese twin if they want to
split yeah yeah Oh hear about your
Siamese twin can talk
area yeah so like here's how it hangs
and there's just cloths like a horse and
like wrapped there's stuff wrapped on it
yeah yeah it'll just chafe oh that's not
for decoration
I thought maybe using like a Mexican
parade or something like okay this is
from the leg Dale the cat-scan thing
it's like penis is here in the middle
can't understand but like that but this
is penis uh-huh this is like skin long
outside and their excess your penis
actually ends way before all this excess
growth I'm so confused
it looks like they skinned a horse I
know this is just like a high whatever a
photography scan but Tom you don't
understand the medical Wow
I'd say you know what I like about is a
whoever searching for the penis guy is
also interested in Diana Princess of
Wales that's why he does it for that
moment
right yeah so walk where people at bay
yes for those faces yeah that's the
truth look at the apart yet why couldn't
he have sex with that it looks like he
could well I mean I think with a
normal-sized woman but no because it's
all it's all hard and skin the last
inches of it or it's just calloused skin
it's not even a penis oh it's like
overgrowth of acid oh give it kisses if
you want you could do you could you hug
it yeah yeah yeah you can hide little
peanuts in the top of it and see if your
dog or your squirrels can find it
that is really creepy I think what she
grew it like she's deliberate yes yes
what's worse though do you think the
hands or the feet that's the real
question
I mean the feet the feet seem like a
much bigger inconvenience you know I
mean like these are terrible enough the
doors and handshakes but like those you
can't put shoes on those Tootsie's yeah
I mean it's just if we could just remove
it from the convenience for her how
about what that disgusted we are I say
the feet I can't even I can't look at
feet normally now you he's big jabber
claws coming off as I think I found I
think this is her on the TLC Oh God
see
[Music]
god that's so much worse that's so much
worse she needs seems I can't exercise
the feed that big no way worse way worse
her only way to normalize this is she
found the dude who's like that's awesome
I love you know perfect well it's the
enabler it's the guy who's like I'll
take care of you I'll Drive you
everywhere I'll put your sneakers on cut
the toes off so that the nails can
dangle I'll paint them I'll make sure I
punched anyone that gets me yeah a
two-yard that's his identity yes what do
you looking at what are you looking at
she's just shopping just like the rest
of you right he's that guy right that
guy his job is to get offended at
everyone else's normal reaction right oh
you never saw a foot before yeah you
never saw an elegant lady's foot no not
like that
that big toe is so so much worse than
everything else Hunter Tony oh this is a
dance class
bye No
five six seven yeah we closed good
loosey goosey she's got the big scissor
hands around his back the toes are
coming in telling him I get a little too
close like that's your life your life is
like watch out for these nails yeah
touch my nails man god she can't work
but you know wax how does she text no
that's the most important thing you're
right yeah
how's she swiping his problem come on he
needs the enabling identity maybe his he
has special being next to someone that
he's perceiving a special you know
that's the things like it's persons
special right here man they got crazy
nails and they've offended me like that
is a party has to be but what if he met
her and she was just kind of like
regular nails no he started to growl oh
and then he's like so baby think you
thinking about - I got you gift
certificate they'll do both tops and
bottoms don't even worry about it
you think he met her after it was big
yeah the thing is if you've ever had
long toenails you know you know when
they're uncomfortable like when you put
on your sneakers like oh this is time to
cut that big toe yeah it's time to go
yeah could you imagine like going past
that I can't stand it for like a day she
can't lay in bed with someone no right I
mean imagine like that cutting you you'd
be like now Bob that would be like for
real like a knife like somebody picking
you in a nice nasty she's the worst he
doesn't get off
the next segment for this show nasty or
not baby wipe kind of this just takes
away any kind of bad feeling well we
have a baby yeah just regular paper you
think we're nasty now but look I got a
thing we're nasty do you think something
like not long nail crew like she's like
people think that people like us with
these nails as a collective Oh
schnitzel you hate long nails too yeah
she's like move on this is disgusting
yeah oh I'll tell you something that
happened to me at ESA age and I was
flying to st. Loup States this weekend
yeah yeah and I had on a comedy works
sweatshirt and it said you know Comedy
Works Denver on the side and the TSA
agent looks at me and she goes yes it
does comedy does work yeah that's a good
one I guess if you didn't know as a
comedy club you'd think that too like oh
what a positive lady that is wearing
that sweatshirt you got to tell the crew
at comedy yeah I said that that's really
comedy and prayer they both
[Laughter]
praise comedy Jesus yeah that's a good
one yeah she was sweet
speaking of all right blind people
somebody yeah we got a lot of questions
about the deaf and the blind
right before you jump into that just off
of blind people it happened to me at a
club this week a guy comes up with his
blind friend and he goes hey we got a
picture Dave's blind and he's got the
stick and everything there's clearly
behind I said yeah sure of course come
over here you know and his so it's me
the I'm me the blind guys in the middle
and his friends on the other side and
his friend has him turned the other way
no so it's the back of it
he's messing with you is like he does
this every time I love that email says
hello mommies I have a totally blind
neighbor that walks his dog around the
neighborhood every day the other day
coming home I see him picking up his
small dogs poop
how did blind people know their dog is
pooping I'm not just smelling something
or taking a break how do they find it
and pick it up keep them high in height
big fan Michael see on the surface that
seems like a stupid question but now
that I think about it yeah this goes
back to degrees of blindness also
because you know somebody can be legally
blind or you know medically they're
they're considered blind and disabled
and in that regard but they might be
have you know just see they can't drive
but they see shadows and shame and
there's like black out total blindness I
think this is probably his neighbor's
probably somebody that has some visual
ability you know he's totally blind you
think so yeah figuring it out super
blind really good stick dog yeah he's
out there with them and then you just
wait for all of the grunting to start
yeah duck so small but give a big dog
the it's like a man like
yeah yeah who was waiting to do that all
through a dog talks no there's no
grunting but you know what it is the
jingle jangle of like they're walking
walking right and then they do that
circle yeah Jean Jean maybe is a poop
Bell on him
I mean finding a specific place to grab
though is kind of dicey right I mean
even with perfect vision you're like oh
you you're real careful usually yeah
that up yeah because I I don't see that
great and but you know I can see and
it's hard to find my dogs sometimes yeah
especially what just goes in the
backyard well maybe so we've been
getting a lot of feedback maybe some
blind people can can maybe be back in
maybe this blind person is faking it
I've done that before to pick up one of
those people I totally a.m. look I can't
run all the time for this and I pretend
like I'm picking it up I do just
terrible terrible yeah I feel bad when I
walk the dog and then um like she goes
or I forget a bag yeah yeah yes and
that's always when they when she goes to
the bathroom in front of ya the
neighbors they're coming out of their
door so maybe now I'll just as we me
meekly go up the street I'll just yell
I'm blind
give me a break I'm blind I'm told by
the way I have done the walk breath fuck
I forgot the bag yeah and I've done the
like yeah it's true before I had a dog
say that dog people are the worst
because they you know is fine stuff and
yeah like they never you know and then
once you have a dog you realize they're
not just enough people they're just
struggling just lazy to I just got our
Sunday's is just dark out it went and
that right we take a ride on a big big
dog shit flattened so like someone else
out time and then the next day I went
the same route and there was a new no
one next to it so like this dog is
shitting on the sidewalk and the person
walked it's like yeah that's for you
shit I'm shitting here I was a
collection of these big dog shits
they're super nice well our dogs are
just are tiny yeah they make like cat
shits it's never like you know no
fucking you know it's yes we had a small
dog that I wanted a small dog well as
your dad you might say to you my father
always the reason we had small dog he
says because a big dog makes big shit
small dog mix small shit always get
small dog there you go for that very
reason yeah he's a poet
[Laughter]
right and like you know the jumping up
on people they get excited and say hello
it's it your ankle is no big deal
my dog's like a horse yeah what is it a
lamb black blood are so cute
they are cute man I mean people come
over she she jumps up she's like the
same height as them yeah and she does I
mean she she shits like a man but can
she shit in your backyard
yeah she's ruined the yard towed you
right my wife right now is with a guy
trying to figure out how to fix the yard
we dogs dog shit out off an area and
that's where they shit have you trained
them it's not very I'll show you how to
do it because it our old house I let
them shit everywhere yeah and then the
whole lawn is ruined and it's like a
minefield but if you tell them like this
is your one area you just train them
okay come on dog shit alley and then
they only go there well she's now just
for peeing also no brown brown and
yellow but the thing is it's gonna mess
up
grass there there but it's rather than
one area one spot yeah it looks like am
i I mean it's all burned out the whole
thing we're thinking about paving it oh
yeah I'm thinking about just putting
like seriously like making it into a
patio hi guys I'm new to the podcast
I've been thinking about this for years
and I think you might have some insight
to offer do retired people dream in
retarded terrible or do they dream just
like you and I are all the dream are all
the people in their dreams retarded I
really like to know thanks guys Daniel
that is a very intensive question but I
have to say you have piqued my interest
I also would like to know from somebody
if let me clarify the question the
question is did they is are the themes
of the dreams retarded people know what
they're asking is their saying is a
retarded person because we asked before
like there's a retarded person know
they're retarded right and we've had a
lot people weigh in like people that
teach but this question is about dreams
and whether or not the dreams are filled
with people that are also returned
oh oh just the just the not not just
what's going on yeah I think so like you
they're not just really excited in them
all to see somebody it's not that kind
of stuff
[Laughter]
I was did a show this weekend and there
were people I was at a comics in Mohegan
Sun oh okay yeah and they said that
there were two special ed teachers there
was a lot of special ed teachers
actually it was like two in one show and
it was like a theme and when I was a kid
we had special ed it was just for the
kids who smoke pot and gave the teacher
the finger right right and they were
like no these are like really special
needs they're like you know they really
yeah they really yeah yeah it's the John
Rizzo volved since we went to school is
what you're saying yeah you know we had
to do volunteer work our senior year of
high school so a friend of mine and I as
seniors we went to this special needs
school and we would volunteer during our
lunch hour there right the one thing
that blew my mind was the range of kids
that were in yeah
yeah there were kids that had attitude
problems right next to kids that could
not speak like they were in a chair and
couldn't move limbs and and you know
like Riley had zero ability to really
participate because I was thinking about
that kid and I was like I wonder if he
dreams if he's just like hello how are
you yeah he's in the shell where he
can't get out and he's you know people
think he's retarded
but then in his dream you see like a
recurring character of like a really
good-looking businessman you know that's
actually really interesting though is he
like stacked is he like adults is the
worst thing would be waking up man you'd
have these awesome dreams feel like you
wake up
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I have to imagine to answer the
question I'm thinking about it I mean I
can dream about retarded people even
though I'm not retarded so maybe the
converse is true but have you got have
you ever dreamt of not that I'm aware of
I mean not yet maybe tonight because I'm
talking about it very vivid dreams and
you remember dreams a lot I dreamt about
prosciutto this morning close your eyes
just look at that picture up there of
that guy Christina is more of a psycho
hi Hitler's thanks I just listened to
your most recent episode had to write a
Cristina's argument that she is less
psycho and has a little thing called
empathy as false
here is why we're Tom laughs at the pain
of others the pain has generally brought
on through their own actions Christina
however laughs at mental illness all the
time which in many cases the person
can't help clearly she is the main
Hitler that's a good point
like painful you know experiences of
others like I feel like it's a defense
can you please show do we have the video
I can pull it up look I'm gonna show you
video we're gonna take video and you
just react to it however I'm not gonna
send him up too much just okay react how
you want Reich how I naturally will now
this is interesting that I'm laughing at
stuff that's involuntary let's say
mental illness is involuntary
whereas this person is saying that those
who harm themselves it's a voluntary go
oh right
interesting so you understood let's see
the video
I mean it's just like first of all I
don't know
everybody has a different reaction but
I've found that it's led time watching
times watching it
and it's town by the way Tom Tom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the driver like how'd that happen
are you so loud no drivers like you
wrecked my car yeah obviously doesn't
like him doesn't give a fuck about that
I don't know if it's funny they got hit
or is funny the reaction is funny there
we go the reaction like the white
whatever the common word he uses for
holy shit yeah he's pretty funny yes
what did you do you don't think this is
funny
um I mean no because I I sense that he's
in a lot of pain I feel badly for him
right I don't really like I don't like
the fact that no one's helping him and
stuff but yeah it's just me but if he if
he reacted the way that you expect
people in pain to react like oh my god
help me yeah if I'd have the eye Devin
54 but that he's just making this crazy
face and screaming these funny duck
noises it's pretty much overrides so
this is the this is the whole thing the
reaction time is talking about that it's
it's a reaction it's how he's reacting
versus that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys like part of the great word is if
it were at all in English it would be
different yes interesting analysis
though that really now I understand now
I don't want to assume you're you have
children their pronouns are you open to
sharing them or know they they okay they
the end they use MS Dems and these kids
do those through them kids that's how
they identify as them do they do they
what they identify as them they identify
as those as those okay were they born
with did you project your own pronoun on
them when they were born
yes what did you label them as
hermaphrodites you did yes Wow and they
disagreed and went to them no those I
believe he said then we decided that
they should be girls whoa bold that's
Charlie's no my uh my wife is in school
now she was going for her degree really
yeah and she is in a gender class oh
really
a whole semester
they and those and them's fascinating
fascinating it's endless
it's endless and your wife and as a
woman my wife is a woman and we have two
girls and the thing for my wife as a
mother when she was in in the class that
you can't say that there was one guy
there said she she said he was obviously
trying to get laid like he looked cool
he was like we talk about these guys all
the light-skinned black guy with the
cool hair and the cool jewelry and just
listen to the discussion and then raised
his hand he's like I don't know I'm just
feeling really I'm just feeling really
sad for those babies like those babies
they split up into boys and girls and
it's hard not to cry when I think about
those big as a mother you know their 40s
in the in the back of the room like oh
Jesus yeah every dude but every dude
takes a lane to get laid yeah are more
overt with their choice right and
they're just like I play sports I'm good
at it all right and some guys are like
I'm gonna I'm gonna show my emotions all
the time right I'm gonna be real
deliberate no hide it seem like yes that
I care after a heated discussion do you
want to talk you want to talk about so
you know now I have a kid to you you
know even if I were to label Ellis a
girl
I believe you're she it doesn't matter I
feel like that gender shit happens on
its own like my boy likes dirt new
trucks and I've done nothing to really
to influence that like I don't cry you
know actually it happens pretty yeah
yeah and there are kids like we didn't
we didn't know kids who obviously we
didn't know if they've identified as a
girl but you news
very effeminate you know very feminine
attracted to girl type things but this
is what's funny about my wife's class if
you just said that you're constantly on
the lookout for how you're screwing up
right so I just said it's so a very
effeminate doing girl things what do you
mean girl things dollies baby why is
that right and she says she sits in
class and all the people like within
earshot around her are all like no
there's girl things and there's boy
right right right
don't you tell the teacher no you know
what everyone feels it everyone knows it
but no one wants to say it out loud
because you get in trouble yeah Todd
there's a class last week and they
brought out baby dolls and all the girls
got excited pulled him out my son took
one look it was like fuck that and ran
across like doesn't even want he's not
interested yeah he should play with the
teacher told me that we should excuse me
play with he we should kind of force
this shit I got listen I'm not trying to
raise him to be a macho man I teach him
to be gentle with animals and with
whatever but if he doesn't want to play
with a doll he's not gonna play with a
doll today sorry you're gonna force him
to do he's snakes rats and whatever
gives you problems cool you you know you
punch them in that's right we teach him
that stuff out just like healthy male
behavior so wait tell me more about the
getting laid guys so it's the yes and
how old is he wait till the next class I
was gonna be like you know I got a
shoulder of today you know it was it was
really upsetting I brought up that thing
about the babies and I got really mad
but then we were for coffee
he slept deeper than I thought it's not
just the jewelry he saves sea turtles
and that's funny because a lot of girls
shared thousands of times on social
media taken on a South Glens Falls High
School Bus involving freshmen Aaron's
Weiner and friend Lea Washington who say
the driver told students that girls and
boys need to sit on different sides of
the bus through the couples in the past
behaving inappropriately the pair
identifying as trans non-binary meeting
they don't see themselves as male or
female but proceeded to sin on the boys
side then they say the driver got angry
trying to explain him the situation like
our gender identity and situation and he
was saying that he didn't care this is
his bus and he's not starting the bus
until he gets what he wants he said that
after I told him that I was comfortable
and I'm going to sit where I'm
comfortable the pair were then kicked
off and waited for another bus to bring
them home Thursday morning's Weiner says
the school's principal and other faculty
stood behind it to just be like hey um
all right well how are you what's your
name what's your pronoun so they got hit
cuz that bus drivers an idiot yeah bus
driver is an asshole but just for being
like your boy or girl that's like when
we talk about like like when I told my
when when non-binary came into the
lexicon yeah I was in most I called my
parents I recorded it and I was like you
know about non-binary my mom was like
you know people that are neither boy nor
female and like you could hear literally
wheels and their heads
[Laughter]
I at my dad's I don't like a bus drivers
totally that guy yeah my mother
yesterday she asked me my wife has
school going he told her about the
gender class and she brought up the
thing about the babies and my mother
just blurts out no as a parent it's your
job to tell them what they are you tell
them you're a boy get over it you're a
boy like boy things yeah it's a that jet
I mean you know our generate we're
learning it every day it's like me I
mean we weren't talking about this last
year like it's coming swiftly
yeah and you're trying to digest it and
trying to do the right thing and try to
that generation it's like I don't know
why my blood pressure so high yeah yeah
I can't I can't sleep without paying
five times what you're a trans Hui yeah
I don't care I also think about this
sometimes even though I don't hear it
really discussed is how this issue and I
don't want to like you know diminish the
people that are going through their
identity crisis but it feels like it is
a not an issue that would ever be
covered in a place where they're lacking
for food you know no all right war yes
yeah if you're in the Congo and you're
like on a second oh well you keep
telling me to line up with the dudes and
they're like wait what yeah why are you
bring this up there's a lion right there
yeah yeah it's like it's only where
things are comfortable that things like
this become yeah well because everyone's
yeah we're not in survival mode right
we're in luxury mode right right you
know theoretically the ability to make
art is if you could be there and be like
I want to talk about my gender and
they'd be like we're going through a
drought if you don't mind holding it yes
spring maybe we could talk about it him
yeah and not to get all political but it
was like you know the California and New
York are kind of going through this and
kind of intellectually getting their
head around it and then they tell people
in areas where none of the fathers have
jobs and they're all freaked out on
opioids and they're like you've got to
change your bathrooms and they're like
dude we're dealing with some other shit
yeah there's no jobs in this town we
grew up in and we're like yeah but you
know everybody's got a P word in there
like right now and I think that was I
think that's what the reaction was is
like you know what you're not in charge
right now we have other stuff we gotta
take sure prior understandable though
you know yeah your priorities not that
oh of course
sometimes you know I don't know
sometimes you just need to make a change
and I think this is a really good
example of a change as somebody needs to
make you know now at this age
Martina desperately wanted to look like
Pamela Anderson so after ten years and
several cosmetic surgeries Martina
transformed her looks into this well I
was a pretty subtle tit she got done but
she wasn't done six months ago Martina
made worldwide headlines with her most
shocking transformation yet through
chemical injections and body
modifications Martina now considers
herself a black woman
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
founded nauseous angry hilarious about
this is that Maury Povich has to treat
this like it's a real he treats all
that's the real trick of it he does it's
like the most baseline bullshit like
unethical undignified and he's basically
this is 60 minutes yeah and that's why
he gets away with it cuz they're like
more is respectable guy he's a fucking
doing garbage and sanitizer in his
dressing room
after he talks to you you know hate
their audience or their fans the level
of like that he hates everything yes
definitely I'm sure a bit of an elitist
guys and like he is but he I did a radio
show once and he was on we were both on
his guests and he was talking about it
and like he wasn't really shitting on it
like really yeah he was like he isn't
elitist like he's had the beautiful
glasses and he's dressed you know
yeah like expensive clothes but he
doesn't either he's keeps up the game
really well yeah really just believes
like no this is just what I do it's just
a crazy show or he knows that he is
blessed enough to find a lane like this
this is this is his Lane and he's locked
it in and he's made a great living oh my
god why why do you see a couple of those
right he's probably like no house in the
Hamptons yes
sure definitely I want to create a more
beautiful body like a Barbie with long
blonde hair and long necks oh my god
much bigger threats I'm not I'm not
black so the black part understands a
cultural identity and it's really fucked
up to just be like I'm black now but the
tits are like that's yeah like it's not
even good you know it's to hurt no one
can wait you're saying us you're saying
it's not good look fucking sweet from
where I'm sitting I mean maybe it's a
girl good girl guy thing but those are
pretty it was pretty good and I also had
a liposuction she gets wrong Bobby her
face is completely different yes she was
kind of cute here yeah does her face
this is C this isn't terrible I mean
this is ridiculous dick ulis but it
isn't terrible
yeah it's okay I mean those girls in LA
oh boy so change for my skin cut up and
no I'm the proud owner of a black skin
today
she has changed her race and now
identifies as a black woman that's
pretty great that is so she knows the
struggle now yeah of course
I mean all you have to do is change your
skin color right I also like to do
photos work on the photos I can see if
you have the curves of Pamela Anderson
yeah yeah yeah
does she look at that picture of Pamela
Anderson and think I did it
oh I do like I got her necklace it says
black girls rock that girl's wrong did
Maury something tells me more he's
production team gave that to her jewelry
you cannot say we gave it to you when
did you get injections to look darker
this generally actually in middle of
January I got three injections in the
belly and that the first week you can
see going down but today is a pay day
this is gonna put tanning salons out of
business three shots in the tummy and
you're good you're good man yeah that's
true why would you even burn your name
you're a black person
[Laughter]
you have to learn a lot
holy she's open yeah just because your
skin is dark no beginning I only wanted
to have more 10 yes when I got in my
these injections yes and three months
[Laughter]
she's he's fully exploiting a severe yes
yeah she's real she's it arranged this
is like a bus stop conversation and
that's that's more ease gift the
absolute insanity is this more yeah
because he's also dancing he's dancing
the line oh yeah like of asking a
sincere question wanting it then he's
also got a play to the crowd knows it's
bullshit he's like really but not too
much right she feels like all you're
totally mocking me probably as tenth
show he's done today that's why it's
called Maury yeah it's good changing
there'll be growing here as also
changing other meanwhile I can see maybe
drawing I can use that so this is
eccentric version yes your husband
Michael is here isn't it Michael nice to
see you
excuse do you feel black I'm a medium I
have got a medium he talks to dead
people
[Laughter]
that is my race I can't wait to go to
Africa because I know it's not my
attention to somebody and it's not it's
not a media attention stuff right it's a
homicide in the day and he was a white
guy like probably 28 maybe no shirt on
just like sneakers in like a baggy baggy
like running pants he's eating a
sandwich and he's rolling on the ground
he's getting up like aggressive like
he's in a mosh pit by himself
would you like to be on TV so we have
you know a lot of times we we feature
dad boners on our show and a dad boner
is somebody is it's a dad somebody in
our age range who gets very excited and
we we've had to then break it down into
two lanes there's the unlike the real
thrill is when somebody gets super
excited about something they shouldn't
get excited about right
for instance this guy excited about
the the highway in Canada it's like why
are you why are you this excited about a
highway you know that's like really like
peak dad boner right then there's other
ones where we feel like it's actually
justified because it's something truly
awesome ok other words somebody will get
excited about an eclipse right but then
you're like well that's actually
something I get excited about but yes
yeah yeah so somebody here's a dad boner
this week but we feel like it's a
justified one oh and you can see why
I get it I mean how boring is fishing
Norman no sharp anything in the water I
mean you got more bait I mean that's why
they're so stoked because it's been a
boring observation that's like the one
thing that happened yeah another beer
yeah we should we try over there by that
rock maybe I caught a fish over there
once yeah it's so great
yeah usually you're just like it's hot
still hot out Suns burning me how's work
how's work going
that's good yeah still still an hour
commute yeah both ways you know he
wasn't a podcast and stuff that's really
big it's good big kill the time yeah
there's books on tape yeah how's
Christine somebody sent in this boring
in the works I worked on this show one
time for Comedy Central about it's
called like 30 minutes over Washington
or something it was basically where we
were mocking politicians ad campaigns
and the way that there is one this is in
Virginia where they tried to I guess use
Top Gun uh-huh but like this dude
without this ad
for a congressman that guys running for
so like I'm like top yeah and that's the
again back there at the bar sure is that
you can't get her to hold a town hall
you know it's funny he has a little Tom
Cruise to his face yeah he's got a
little bit like someone in high school
said he looked like Tom Cruise yeah and
this is the moment where he puts it all
twisted all right I know that his like
his his campaign manager was like you're
a vet you're gonna wear a shirt that
says that in these ads like are you sure
he was like a hundred percent like
you're gonna care veteran so that when
people are voting they remember that
part too besides you're awesome Tom
Cruise commercial you can't get a Town
Hall
do you one better than that we've lost
that lovin feeling no
are you sure now it's so embarrassing
oh wait can I put something over my head
you have something like that extra penis
skin no the only mistake he's made is
that he picked the wrong Tom Cruise
movie yeah this is out of a straight out
of cocktail all right this is cocktail
and the whole bar stops and listens to
are you sure this isn't Top Gun
well he's combining elements of Top Gun
with you think Top Gun but he's made a
mistake he should interest a little
Kokomo yeah he should have been flipping
bottles the crazy like the whole bar
stops and like right like hundreds of
people to stop and like turn as Tom
Cruise says something about tequila
what's his his ad could have been like
our districts going to shit and it's
boring around here for drinks let's have
some fucking fun again but I think
[Applause]
[Music]
I bet this works for him though do you
think so there was a lot of dopes out
there that are like this is great then
the opposition walks out like she leaves
right nice work Dan I'm Dan Heller I
approve of town halls bad singing in
this message
[Music]
hany self-aware I mean at the end he's
aware that it's kind of corny that a
veteran I'm sure with the army in case
you're wondering what branch he's
running for he is a Democrat running for
10th district in Virginia dan Helmer Wow
wish you the best
dan I please keep making these they're
really good it's up more uncomfortable
than the nail lady yeah no no ladies
like what yeah this is like the seat
like yes
what just me just sad yeah it's like
bummed me out too it's like if someone
tries to sing you know and on those
shows like on those audition shows or
you're like yeah
dammit stop singing like you can't do it
no one told you why do we feel great
like why did it make us sad because I
think you can register
especially of your performer when you're
like this bat is this is a bad show
you're doing you're not doing well right
now right makes you uncomfortable yeah
to see somebody like or even worse it's
when you're watching that person and
they're killing yeah yeah you know it's
bad and other people are approving of it
that that's true you're just like oh
what am i that far from what that is
yeah you know what I mean that like oh
maybe we're all just hacky yeah true
there's something that registers
differently I think if you perform when
you watch a performance yeah you write
you read it differently Oh completely
yeah maybe that's what it is I'm gonna
go now
yeah I think it started for us I think
it's that it's it was so out of his
comfort zone like it was painful to
watch him that's a good point yeah
thanks maverick we did it like he's just
staring at whoever he was talking to his
he's terrified no no it's bad well I
sent that he's not comfortable because
he's really an experience and I feel
nervous for him so I'm like oh like I'm
so uncomfortable and I'd like this for
your neck she has Netflix special coming
out right yeah yeah so it's about to
come out what if you did like a hey why
don't you watch my Netflix special and
we like parity and I would love to you
like something from Legally Blonde or
something yeah for sure you have some
good lines in there yeah I object
she's great it's a great way to do it
I'd love to do it and you can turn the
camera I'm Christina P I approve this
message
I like totally yeah is there a better
one probably probably is there a better
worse idea that you know is there better
movie than Legally Blonde like you would
like to do like is there another
favorite Rocco that new documentary gosh
my god the original Rocky
No the Italian porn star Rocco
oh speaking of being bummed yeah you'll
feel sad there's a lot of sadness but
it's a it's pretty good right amazing
document that one to watch when the
girls are around it's nothing I watch
from the girls room yeah literally
nothing to watch but I just finished
season three of narcos thing big thumbs
up to that yeah oh you finished it
excellent
we started Ozark yeah I did too really
good I'm pretty deep into that okay it
is good but that documentary is it's
it's a wide range of him and this is a
guy who's done really hardcore crazy
form for 30 years that's the part that
well I think to the most that we stood
like this stood out was like you know if
the guy was like 24 you'd be like yeah I
mean some people are gonna go that way
right but like the fact that he's 50
something yeah and he's like why if I
have a couple kids and then he's just
like stepping on necks and like just
joking girls fast he's very revealing in
it like he yeah yeah dark thoughts
really yeah maybe I'll watch it with the
kids yeah
Tom Papa where compete see you my
podcast is called come to Papa
and we've been doing a lot of live shows
with it it's adorable just go to town
papa calm you can find there's hot gas
my tour dates all that stuff I'm going
to Eugene Oregon next week awesome
Portland I did both this year oh yeah
yeah were you doing Eugene our Rialto
and no no that's that's Denver or
Loveland Eugene some theater in Eugene
the Holtz okay and then one in Portland
two great towns yeah more love we're
going up there and top up was an amazing
comedian if you've never seen him go see
him live he's really one of the best
it's really true it's true really good
he's really guys are great to normal
person Christina P has a
special mother and wire that premiering
October 10th on yes Netflix queue it up
wheat right next to your Rocco
documentary wants them back back please
die and then I think I saw Legally
Blonde parody about that special yeah
it's pretty good it's pretty good I have
I put the the signed vinyls of
completely normal are in the store if
you wanted those and I also signed the
left over posters from the Denver taping
those are in the store as well just did
that right I did that last weekend now
how'd it go it was awesome yeah it was a
lot of fun awesome
yes super cool it's gonna be a great
special I'm excited for it it comes out
as good as you think I know I know and
it's never as bad as you think it's
exactly that it's just somewhere in the
mess somewhere in the middle yeah but
always great for the fans yeah but yeah
please go to Tom Segura dot-com check
out the the live dates I told you
Toronto and we'll see you soon and the
stores there as well thank you Tom for
coming today this is the best you're so
good love your podcast and hopefully you
invited me over so fine the dogs this is
a nice place I'm sorry about the street
I couldn't help am I gonna be able to go
home no you have to stay here oh how
long how many days just like six seven
days okay be good we'll see you next
week thanks a lot guys you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay how often am I doing this you have
to do every day and do your control